16:48 and the thirty years war is over
this completely devastated the holy
roman empire but a certain state the
electorate of brandenburg-prussia ruled
by a certain frederick william's since
1640 did gain some territory so a brief
overview of brandenburg-prussia it was
ruled by the Royal House of Hohenzollern
it was mostly Protestant it spoke German
and as the name suggests it was divided
into two territories Brandenburg whose
capital was Berlin was an electorate
within the Holy Roman Empire
this meant that Frederick William also
known as the great elector could cast a
vote on who could become the next Holy
Roman Emperor this was important because
it meant that he could elicit bribes
from candidates and it also gave his
territories their greater rights and
prestige the other half of his territory
was called juco Prussia whose capital
was Konigsberg which was outside of the
Holy Roman Empire but was a vassal state
of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
thus giving it the problem of having two
different overlords who one day may want
different things
Brandenburg had recently gained the
territory of eastern Pomerania meaning
that brandenburg was connected to the
Baltic Sea which gave their ample new
opportunities for trade Frederick
William felt that this access to the sea
would be great for Brandenburg and he
sought to emulate the Dutch Republic and
become a great and wealthy trading
nation they tried but ultimately a
maritime Empire was not Brandenburg
brush's destiny the great elector also
sought to strengthen brandenburg brush's
international position by introducing a
standing army this was a difficult
process since he wanted it to be
centrally funded and not paid for and
thus beholden to any of his nobles he
achieved this after a few concessions to
his nobles by about 1655 he had a
standing army of around 25,000 men so
Frederick William did not wish to remain
a vassal for much longer to major events
happened in the 1650s which helped with
this one the Sodom of Russia invaded the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth in 1654
and to so did the Swedish because their
King Charles the temped wanted some more
land before the Russians took it all the
great elector on behalf of his Overlord
attempted to resist the swedish invaders
but was defeated he retreated regrouped
his forces and in an act of genius
submitted to Swedish overlordship in
1656 the brandenburg-prussia then
successfully fought alongside the
swedish into 1657 this was when John the
second king of Poland in the ground Duke
of Lithuania offered prussia freedom
from vassalage if it switch sides which
it did again the great electors forces
helped the polish-lithuanian repulsed
the swedish invasion and by 1660 the war
was over and prussia was a sovereign
duchy brandenburg was
the overlordship of the holy roman
empire though but it was progress at
least the standing army that Frederick
William had built continued to grown by
the 1670s it stood at almost 40,000 men
brandenburg-prussia was still in
financial trouble though but Frederick
Williams efforts at encouraging seaborne
trade made some headway
in 1682 he granted a charter to the
Brandenberg African company who set up
trading posts in African holdings with
which to sell slaves to North America he
was in 1688 that the great electors
successful reign came to an end due to a
small case of death he was succeeded by
his son Frederick who much like his
father had lofty ambitions these were
overridden by the need to defend that
which his father had achieved since both
Sweden and Poland Lithuania wouldn't
hesitate to undo any of it he thus made
an alliance with the hapsburgs in order
to safeguard his rome against them
whilst also providing well-trained
troops for the nine years war against
frances louis xiv when though he had his
grandson crown king of spain in 1700 the
hapsburgs knew that there would be war
which they would want Brandenburg
Prussian troops for but in return for
his support Frederick wanted only one
thing he wanted a crown Frederick was
going to crown himself irrespective of
what anyone else wanted however since
the Habsburgs now needed his
professional soldiers he could get some
outside recognition in 1701 he had
himself crowned as the Prussian King
although be aware that he wasn't the
King of Prussia he was the king in
Prussia this was so that his lands in
the Holy Roman Empire wouldn't have a
king other than the king of the Romans
which was one of the titles of the Holy
Roman Emperor it was also because this
territory in the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth was also known as Prussia
and they wanted to be sure that there
wasn't any confusion so as the King in
Prussia Frederick now Frederick the
first gained a massive amount of
prestige in his coronation marks the
beginning of Prussia's rise not in
geopolitical terms that is that was
before this but in historical terms
since the emphasis in Brandenburg
Prussia was now on Prussia Frederick's
reign saw him create the Royal Academy
of Arts and Sciences of Prussia was
fairly uneventful until his death in
1713 he was succeeded by his son
Frederick William the first this was
because the previous one was to King and
so didn't get a number the new king
started out by joining the great
northern war against Sweden from which
they gained this territory so Frederick
William was an absolute monarch at least
ideally he attempted to control the
local nobility and centralize the state
but the nobles weren't too keen to go
along with it one of the most notable
reforms of Frederick William brought in
was the school's Edict of 1717 which
expanded primary education throughout
the realm well most of it
in certain parts the local
ability were unhappy and resisted
implementing it or more specifically
paying for it the King also sought to
speed up population growth since
Prussia's population still hadn't
recovered from the 30 Years War he did
this by once again emulating the Dutch
in inviting many thousands of
Protestants from across the Holy Roman
Empire to settle in Prussia Protestants
at this time were generally speaking
more literate and held specialist trades
meaning that they could provide an
economic boost to Prussia the reforms of
Frederick William the first weren't
simply limited to things such as trade
in education there were also a great
deal of reforms to the military which
stops being surprising when you learn
that he's also known as the soldier King
it was during his reign that the army
grew considerably necessitating an
increase in the size of the Prussian
bureaucracy army recruitment was
streamlined and tactics were improved
Frederick William the first also ranked
serving soldiers above civilians and
serving noblemen above their peers which
created a culture that valued the army
and encouraged everyone to join this is
why by 1740 the Prussian army was 80,000
strong and pretty formidable the size of
the army is why Prussia has a reputation
of being very martial and has famously
been described as being an army with a
state or being hatched from a cannonball
Frederick William the first rain came to
an end in 1740 when he died and he was
succeeded by his son the most famous
Prussian of all Frederick the second
better known as Frederick the Great
so Frederick had inherited a large
well-equipped and well-trained army and
since his father was a prudent man he
had lots of money too also he succeeded
the throne at a time when all of the
major powers in Europe were either
bankrupt at war or having internal
issues which gave him freedom to
maneuver to maneuver straight into
Habsburg Silesia that is he did this
just after and purchase the sick died
and was succeeded by his daughter Maria
Theresa she would inevitably be dealing
with all sorts of succession issues and
so as far as Frederick was concerned may
as well grab a free Silesia they started
the first Silesian war which saw a quick
occupation of most of the province
the Austrians counter-attacked the next
year with the Prussians with their world
discipline professional army managed to
defeat the Austrians at the Battle of
more vids this battle actually saw
Frederick flee the field but his field
marshal count Kurt von Schwerin went on
to defeat the Austrians which taught him
not to run away at this point all of
Europe wanted in and so War of the
Austrian succession
however in 1742 Prussia and Austria
signed the Treaty of Berlin which
relinquished Austrian control of Silesia
to the Prussians this peace treaty would
last for a whopping two years before
again Frederick declared war on Austria
just to make sure they couldn't take
Silesia back in 1745 the
Austrians confirmed Prussia's ownership
of Silesia and extremely wealthy profits
and hereafter pressure can be considered
a great power
so after Austria Russia and France made
an alliance in 1756 Prussia quickly made
one with Britain Frederick was convinced
that Austria was going to try and retake
so leisure and so he made his move and
invaded Austria wait no he didn't he
made it Saxony he did this to take its
army and money for himself to lessen the
burden of fighting Austria this
kick-started the third Silesian war
which tracked everyone else's allies
including the already fighting Britain
and France into it and suddenly 7 Years
War
at first things went well for Prussia
but as the war dragged on things turned
against Frederick in the Russians
advanced taking Eastern Prussia
fortunately for Frederick the pro
Prussian Peter the 3rd succeeded to the
Russian throne and thus called off the
warm returned everything which was nice
of him after France was defeated by
Britain Austria and Prussia made peace
and agreed that no territories would
change in the hundreds of thousands of
people had died for nothing with all of
this in mind it would be easy to see
Frederick the Great's reign as being
nothing but a series of wars but he was
a prudent monarch and a reformer too he
strengthened the economy by freeing up
trade within his territories he stored
grain after good harvest so that when
the bad harvest came his people wouldn't
starve his realm also saw early
industrialization but a significant part
of this was because he simply nicked
Silesia Prussia also played host to the
Enlightenment to produce one of the most
famous intellectuals of all time
Immanuel Kant who argued that Frederick
was the embodiment of enlightened
absolutism and that he was so
enlightened that unwavering obedience to
him wasn't a burden but a privilege
Frederick's ambitions weren't limited to
Silesia he had designs on Polish Prussia
since he wanted to connect his
territories the Prussians Russians and
Austrians conspired to place a candidate
on the elected polish-lithuanian throne
which they did in 1772 one problem the
new ruler Stan you soif the second
didn't go along with this and started to
strengthen the Commonwealth as such the
three powers opted for a different route
they openly and violently dismembered
the Commonwealth in 1772 the three
powers reduced the size of Poland
markedly and what is called the first
partition of Poland because fun fact
there were more the first partition so
Prussia gained this land polish Prussia
finally connecting the lands of Prussia
with Brandenburg and finally allowing
Frederick to change his title from the
king in Prussia to the King of Prussia
since now he owned all of it Frederick's
reign would last until his death in 1786
and his legacy would be to bequeath a
great power to his nephew and successor
Frederick William the second because
apparently in Prussia there was some
sort of a name shortage anyway frederick
ii left Prussia
much stronger Kingdom than the one he
had inherited it was off these
foundations that he and his forebears
had built the Prussia would rise to
eventually unify Germany Prussia had
risen from being both under the
overlordship of Poland Lithuania and the
Holy Roman Empire to having ripped
territory from both and establishing
itself as a great power most of this can
be attributed to the military and
economic reforms of Frederick and his
predecessors if you had to pick a
territory that could one day threaten
Britain France Russia and Austria and
Prussia likely would not have been your
top choice yet through the reigns of
four long-lived and visionary sovereigns
Prussia would go on to do just that and
much of this success can be attributed
to Prussia's professional standing army
which gave it the capacity to punch well
above its weight Frederick's army was
the envy of much of Europe but be aware
it wasn't invincible as would be
demonstrated in the coming wars with
France I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching and a special
thanks to Thomas guest Strich Adam
Harvey Winston Cawood and James
Bissonnette if you'd like to learn more
about pressure at this time then there
are some book recommendations in the
description below
you